de la fase piloto del Proyecto Ignorancia
de la Fundación Gapminder que dirijo,
e iniciamos esto el año pasado,
con mi jefe, que es también mi hijo, Ola Rosling. (Risas)
Él es cofundador y director
y quería, Ola me dijo,
que fuéramos más sistemáticos
al luchar contra la ignorancia devastadora.
El programa piloto ya rebela esto,
que muchos en el público puntúan peor que el azar,
así que debemos pensar en ideas preconcebidas.
y algunas de las principales
están relacionadas con la distribución mundial de la renta
Miren como era en 1975.
El número personas para cada ingreso,
desde un dólar por día...
(Aplausos)
Vean que aquí hay una joroba
alrededor de un dólar por día,
y luego una joroba aquí
entre 10 y 100 dólares.
El mundo tenía dos grupos,
era como un camello con dos jorobas,
los pobres y los ricos,
y unos pocos entre ellas.
Pero vean cómo ha cambiado.
Conforme avanzamos, lo que cambia
es que la población mundial ha aumentado
y las jorobas empiezan a mezclarse.
La joroba más baja se mezcla con la joroba más alta;
el camello muere y ahora tenemos un mundo dromedario
con una sola joroba.
El porcentaje de pobreza ha disminuido.
Aun así es horrible
que tantos permanezcan en la extrema pobreza.
Todavía tenemos este grupo, cerca de mil millones,
pero eso puede acabarse ahora.
El reto que tenemos
es alejarnos de eso, entender dónde está la mayoría,
y que se muestra muy claramente, en esta pregunta
Preguntamos cuál era el porcentaje mundial
de niños de un año de edad
vacunados contra sarampión y otras cosas
que hemos padecido por muchos años:
¿un 20 %, 50 % o 80 %?
Aquí están las respuestas del público norteamericano y sueco.
Vean el resultado de los suecos:
ya saben la respuesta correcta.
(Risas)
¿Quién demonios es el profesor de salud global en ese país?
Bueno, soy yo. Soy yo.
(Risas)
Es muy duro esto, es muy duro.
(Aplausos)
Sin embargo, el enfoque de Ola
para realmente medir lo que sabemos, levantó titulares
y CNN publicó los resultados en su web
con las preguntas, millones de respuestas,
y creo que cerca de 2000 comentarios;
y uno de estos era:
"Apuesto a que nadie de los medios de comunicación pasó el test", dijo.
Y Ola me dijo: "Toma estos aparatos,
estás invitado a una rueda de prensa;
dáselos y mide lo que los medios saben".
Y señoras y señores,
por primera vez, los resultados informales
de una conferencia con los medios de comunicación de los EE. UU.
y después, con los de la Unión Europea.
(Risas)
Ven, el problema no es que la gente
no lea o no escuche a los medios.
El problema es que los propios medios no lo saben.
¿Qué deberíamos hacer, Ola?
¿Tenemos algunas ideas?
(Aplausos)
Ola Rosling: Sí, tengo alguna idea, pero primero
siento mucho que les ganasen los chimpancés.
Con suerte podré consolarlos
cuando vean que no fue culpa suya, en realidad.
Después, les daré algunos trucos
para ganar a los chimpancés en el futuro.
Esto es básicamente lo que haré.
Pero antes, vean porque somos tan ignorantes.
Todo empieza en este sitio.
Es una ciudad del norte de Suecia: Hudiksvall.
Este es el barrio donde crecí,
un barrio con un gran problema
En realidad, con el mismo problema
que el resto de los vecindarios,
donde crecieron Uds.
No es representativo ¿vale?
Me dio una visión sesgada
de cómo es la vida en este planeta.
Así que esta es la primera pieza del puzle de la ignorancia.
Tenemos un sesgo personal,
diferentes experiencias de las comunidades
y personas con que vivimos,
a lo que hay que añadir, además, la escuela,
que es otro problema.
Me gustan las escuelas,
pero los profesores suelen enseñar una visión obsoleta del mundo,
porque aprendieron algo cuando fueron a la escuela
y ahora describen ese mundo a sus estudiantes
sin mala intención, está claro,
y estos libros, impresos claro,
están caducos en este mundo de cambios constantes.
Y no tiene ningún sentido
seguir enseñando con un material tan anticuado.
Es en esto en lo que nos centraremos.
Tenemos unos datos caducos,
además de nuestra visión personal sesgada.
Lo que sucede después son las noticias.
Un buen periodista sabe cómo elegir
las historias que harán titulares
y que la gente leerá porque son sensacionalistas
Los eventos inusuales son más interesantes, ¿no?
Y se exageran,
sobre todo las cosas que nos dan miedo.
Un tiburón que ataca a un sueco
será un titular durante semanas en Suecia,
Por lo tanto es difícil evitar
estas tres fuentes de información sesgadas.
Nos bombardean
y llenan la cabeza con un montón de ideas extrañas;
y a esto hay que añadirle lo que
nos hace ser humanos: nuestra intuición humana.
Fue buena en la evolución,
nos ayudó a generalizar
y sacar conclusiones muy, muy rápidamente.
Nos ayudó a exagerar lo que nos daba miedo,
y buscar causalidades donde no las hay,
para después darnos una especie de falsa confianza
por la que nos creemos los mejores conductores
por encima de la media.
Todos respondieron a esta pregunta:
"Sí, yo conduzco mejor".
Vale, fue bueno desde un punto de vista evolutivo,
pero ahora cuando es sobre la visión del mundo,
es exactamente la razón por la que está al revés.
Las tendencias que aumentan están sin embargo cayendo
y lo mismo al contrario,
y en este caso, los chimpancés usan nuestra intuición contra nosotros,
que se convierte en debilidad, en vez de fortaleza.
Se suponía que era nuestra fortaleza, ¿no?
¿Cómo resolvemos este problema?
Primero, hay que medirlo
para luego arreglarlo.
Al medirlo podemos comprender
cuál es el patrón de ignorancia.
Iniciamos el proyecto piloto el año pasado
y ahora estamos seguros de que encontraremos
mucha ignorancia por todo el mundo,
y la idea es realmente
escalarla a todos los dominios
o dimensiones del desarrollo global,
como el clima, las especies en peligro de extinción, los derechos humanos,
la igualdad de género, la energía y las finanzas.
Todos los sectores tienen datos
y hay organizaciones que intentan
concienciarnos sobre estos datos.
Por eso, empezamos a contactar con algunas
como WWF, Amnistía Internacional y Unicef,
para preguntarles, ¿cuáles son sus datos preferidos
que creen que el público desconoce?
Bien, reuní esos datos.
Imagínense una gran lista, con digamos, 250 datos.
Y luego preguntamos al público
para ver cuál tenía la peor puntuación.
Así conseguimos una lista más corta
con resultados terribles,
como algunos de los ejemplos de Hans,
y no tuvimos problemas en encontrar
esos resultados terribles.
¿Qué vamos a hacer con esta pequeña lista?
Bueno, la convertimos en un certificado de conocimiento,
un certificado de conocimiento global,
que pueden usar, si son una gran organización
una escuela, una universidad o quizás una agencia de prensa
que les certifica como conocedores globales.
Básicamente, significa que no contratamos a nadie
que puntuó como los chimpancés.
Desde luego no deberían hacerlo.
Puede ser que en 10 años a partir de ahora,
si este proyecto triunfa,
estén sentados en una entrevista
rellenando esta especie de loco conocimiento global.
Ahora, volvamos a los trucos prácticos.
¿Cómo van a triunfar?
Hay, desde luego, una manera,
que es acostarse muy tarde todas las noches
y aprenderse de memoria los datos,
leyendo todos estos informes.
Esto nunca pasará,
incluso Hans no cree que pasará,
La gente no tiene tiempo.
La gente quiere atajos y aquí están los atajos.
Hay que fortalecer nuestra intuición de nuevo.
Poder generalizar.
Y les voy a mostrar algunos trucos
en los que los malentendidos se transforman
en reglas prácticas.
Empecemos con un equívoco,
muy extendido:
todo va a peor.
Lo oímos a menudo, e incluso, Uds. mismos lo piensan.
La otra forma de pensar es que las cosas mejorarán.
Así que cuando se enfrenten a una pregunta
y no estén seguros deberían adivinar "mejor".
No se inclinen por lo peor, ¿vale?
Esto les ayudará a conseguir mejor puntuación en los test.
(Aplausos)
Esta era la primera
Hay ricos y pobres
y la diferencia es cada vez mayor.
Hay una gran desigualdad.
Sí, vivimos en un mundo desigual,
pero al mirar los datos hay una joroba.
¿Vale? Si se sienten inseguros
inclínense por "la mayoría de la gente está en la mitad".
Les ayudará a conseguir la repuesta correcta.
La siguiente idea preconcebida es que
los países y la gente primero necesitan ser muy ricos,
para desarrollarse socialmente,
con chicas en la escuela y estar listos para los desastres naturales.
No, no, no. Eso está mal.
Miren, en la gran joroba del medio
ya hay chicas en la escuela.
Por tanto, si están inseguros, piensen en que
"la mayoría ya lo tiene";
cosas como la electricidad, chicas en la escuela y este tipo de cosas.
Son solo reglas prácticas,
y lógicamente no se pueden aplicar a todo,
pero así es como pueden generalizar.
Vean la ultima
Si, esta es buena.
Los tiburones son peligrosos. No.
Bueno sí, pero no son tan importantes
en las estadísticas globales, es lo que quiero decir.
A mí me dan mucho miedo los tiburones.
Tan pronto como veo una pregunta sobre algo que temo,
puede ser terremotos, otras religiones,
quizá terroristas o tiburones,
cualquier cosa que me atemorice,
asuman que van a exagerar el problema.
Esta es la regla práctica.
Desde luego hay peligros que también son grandes.
Los tiburones matan muy poca gente, es lo que deberían pensar.
Con estas cuatro reglas prácticas,
podrán contestar mejor que los chimpancés,
porque los chimpancés no pueden hacer esto.
No puede generalizar este tipo de reglas.
Y felizmente podrán darle la vuelta al mundo
y ganar a los chimpancés, ¿vale?
(Aplausos)
Este es un enfoque sistemático,
pero la pregunta ahora es ¿es esto importante?
Sí, es importante comprender la pobreza,
la extrema pobreza y como combatirla,
y como llevar las chicas a la escuela.
Cuando se den cuenta de que esto está pasando podrán comprenderlo.
Pero ¿es importante para todo el mundo?
¿Qué pasa con los ricos, el otro extremo en la escala?
Diría que sí, que muy importantes
por la misma razón.
Si tienen una visión del mundo basada en datos actuales
podrán tener la oportunidad de comprender
que vendrá en el futuro.
Volvamos a esas dos jorobas en 1975
cuando nací,
y selecciono Occidente.
Estos son los actuales países de la Unión Europea y EE. UU.
Vean como Occidente y el resto se comparan
en términos de cómo son de ricos.
Esta es la gente que puede permitirse
viajar en avión al extranjero en vacaciones.
En 1975, solo podía el 30 %
de los que vivían fuera de la Unión Europea y EE. UU.
Pero esto ha cambiado.
Primero, vean el cambio hasta hoy, 2014.
Actualmente es 50/50.
Se acabó la dominación occidental.
Eso es bueno. ¿Qué ocurrirá a continuación?
¿Ven esta gran joroba? ¿Ven cómo se mueve?
Hice un experimento, visité la web del Fondo Monetario Internacional.
para ver el pronóstico del PIB en los próximos 5 años,
y poder usarlo como una predicción para los próximos 5 años,
siempre que la diferencia de ingresos entre los países sea la misma.
Lo hice, e incluso fui más lejos.
Usé estos 5 años para los próximos 20,
a la misma velocidad, solo como un experimento de lo que podría pasar.
Vengan al futuro.
En 2020, es el 57 % en el resto
En 2025, es el 63 %, 2030, 68%.
Y en 2035 Occidente es superado en el mercado de los consumidores ricos.
Estas son solo proyecciones del PIB per cápita en el futuro.
El 73 % de los consumidores ricos
vivirán fuera EE. UU. y Europa
Por eso creo que es una buena idea para una compañía usar este certificado
para asegurarse de tomar decisiones basadas en los datos del futuro.
Mucha gracias
(Aplausos)
Bruno Gisani: ¡Hans y Ola Rosling!